see you're a curious lover of science
what do you think of the efforts that
Elon Musk is doing with space
exploration with electric vehicles with
autopilot
sort of getting into the space of
autonomous vehicles was boring under la
and neural link trying to communicate
brain machine interfaces communicate
between machines and human brains what's
really inspiring I mean look at the
fandom that he's amassed it's it's not
common for someone like that to have
such a following and zilean you're a
nerd yeah so it's really it's really
exciting but I also think that a lot of
responsibility comes with that kind of
power so like if I met him I would love
to hear how he feels about the
responsibility he has when when there
are people who are such a fan of your
ideas and your dreams and share them so
closely with you you have a lot of power
and he didn't always have that you know
he wasn't born as Elon Musk well he was
but well he was named that later but the
point is that that that I want to know
the psychology of becoming a figure like
him well I don't even know how to phrase
the question right but it's a question
about what do you do when you were
you're following your fans become so you
know large that it's almost bigger than
you and how do you how do you
responsibly manage that and maybe it
doesn't worry him at all and that's fine
too
but I'd be really curious and I think
there are a lot of people that go
through this when they realize whoa
there are a lot of eyes on me there are
a lot of people who really take what I
say very earnestly and take it to heart
and will defend me and who that's that's
some that that can be dangerous and and
you have to be responsible with it both
in terms of impact in society and
psychologically for the individual just
just the the burden psychologically and
on the on yeah yeah how does he
how does he think about that part of his
persona well let me throw that right
back at you because in some ways you're
just a funny guy that gotten a humongous
following a funny guy with a curiosity
mm-hmm
you've got a huge following how do you
psychologically deal with the
responsibility in many ways you ever
reach in many ways bigger than you are
musk what is your what is the burden
that you feel in educating being one of
the biggest educators in the world where
everybody's listening to you and
actually everybody like that most of the
world that uses YouTube for educational
material trust you as a source of good
strong scientific thinking it's a burden
and I try to approach it with a lot of
humility and sharing like I'm not out
there doing a lot of scientific
experiments I am sharing the work of
real scientists and I'm celebrating
their work and the way that they think
and the power of curiosity but I want to
make it clear at all times that like
look you know we don't know all the
answers and I don't think we're ever
going to reach a point where we're like
wow and there you go that's the universe
it's this equation you plug in some
conditions or whatever and you do the
math and you know what's gonna happen
tomorrow I don't think we're gonna reach
that point but I I think that there is a
tendency to sometimes believe in science
and become elitist and become I don't
know hard when in reality it should
humble you and make you feel smaller I
think there's something very beautiful
about feeling very very small and very
weak and to feel that you need other
people hmm so I try to keep that in mind
and say look thanks for watching Vsauce
is not I'm not Vsauce you are when I
start the episodes I say hey Vsauce
Michael here Lea sauce and Michael are
actually a different thing in my mind I
don't know if that's always clear but
yeah I have to approach it that way
because it's not about me
yeah so it's not even you're not feeling
a responsibility you're just sort of
plugging into this big thing that is
scientific exploration of our reality
and you're a voice that represents a
bunch but here you're just plugging into
this big vsauce ball that others
millions of others have plugged into
yeah I'm just hoping to encourage
curiosity and you know responsible
thinking and an embracement of doubt and
being okay with that
you